10 puijalon le fait qu'il ait tant de
gens qui sentent en insécurité
ça devrait cacher c'est pas que ça me
fait sourire parce que c'est un sujet
trop trop trop trop important pour un
poids rire en réalité je sentiment
d'insécurité il me fait penser au même
sentiment d'insécurité que peuvent avoir
les gens milieu rural qu'en jamais vu un
voleur un incendie et qui se tourner
vers l'extrême droite prétextant qu'ils
avaient des exactions c'est la même
chose pour les accidents c'est à dire
comment fait tellement une version
médiatisé aujourd'hui le sentiment
d'insécurité se retrouvent vis-à-vis des
chasseurs je rappellerai que plus le
comble de la chose c'est que ces
accidents qu'on a eu lieu fait baisser
considérablement les dernières années
mais l'augmentation des accidents est
arrivé par la faute des animalistes
c'est à dire qu'on a demandé aux
chasseurs de ne plus pratiquer avec la
chevrotine pour ne pas blesser les
animaux d'utiliser des armes de guerre
d'accord donc l'utilisation d'armes de
guerre d'un des concepts ou aujourd'hui
lui le mitage du territoire l'arrivée de
nombreux animaux l'obligation de réguler
fait qu'aujourd'hui on utilise des armes
hyper puissante dans des zones
extrêmement sensible et donc il a fallu
former les chasseurs pendant des années
les anime fair du décor pour faire
chuter et malgré tout cet accident mais
même un accident ces matières un de trop
il faut s'imaginer c'est comme si demain
pour la sécurité routière on disait aux
gens au lieu de rouler avec une
quatrième voiture électrique on va vous
mettre une ferrari mais 600 chevaux vous
allez voir de suite comme il valoir
d'accidents en route et il fallait
maîtriser ça on l'a fait c'est pas
suffisant moi j'ai fait j'ai bien vu que
le président national federation of une
vidéo pour demain des encore aux
chasseurs d'être extrêmement responsable
je les fais pareil je suis toujours
remonter à chaque fois qu'un accident de
trop parce que c'est notre
responsabilité à chacun mais de venir
dire que 1 million de chasseurs tous les
jours qu'ils pratiquent mettre un ratio
sur ces accidents la disputer j'aimerais
bien qu'on se positionne sur d'autres
accidents de la vie aujourd'hui qui sont
catastrophiques où il ya des milliers de
morts ça ne justifie pas à notre action
mais quand même la focalisation canif
est bon là on a bien compris qu'on
arrive en période électorale et que nos
amis des écologistes plus et les
animalistes ben ils se font du beurre de
ces choses là
[Musique]